design in all its forms is
everywhere your smartphone your glasses
the font on your car's in dash display
every aspect of your life has been
shaped by designers and we have entered
an age when powerful new tools and
Technology put new opportunities at
their fingertips every day call it the
era of silicon modern designers can now
create products that would have seemed
impossible a decade ago combined the
physical and digital worlds customizing
products beyond our wildest dreams and
developing seamless experiences that
feel truly
magical in our latest installment of
design life a yearly manual for gadgets
and gear you'll find our favorite
products that help us get through our
day allowing us to live richer and more
connected
lives through this technological
Evolution designers have had to increase
increase their fluency in a multitude of
fields from film to
food and this fall we are hosting wired
by Design where 200 of our colleagues
and friends will come together at
Skywalker sound to discuss how design in
all its forms can build a better
future